les violences conjugales en hausse
depuis le début du confinement pour y
faire face
les bénévoles du 39 19 le numéro
national d'urgence sont à pied d'oeuvre
pour aider les femmes victimes de
violences un dispositif créé en 2007
lorsque je garde un faux bonjour pas un
numéro d'urgence mais d'orientation pour
les femmes victimes de violences
conjugales
des psychologues sont allés coûte elle
conseille en français en arabe en
espagnol avant le 39 19 d'autres
dispositifs similaires existaient pour
écouter et aider les femmes battues
principalement à l'échelle locale
les premières permanences téléphoniques
d'urgence voient le jour dans les années
70 les associations féministes en sont à
l'initiative des bénévoles apportaient
leur aide morale médicale et juridique
nous voulons les aider à s'aider elle
même c'est l'essai l'impossibilité pour
qu'elle puisse en sortir au début des
années 70 il n'existait aucun centre
d'hébergement pour les femmes battues en
france ces permanences d'urgence et est
donc précieuse pour les victimes
maintenant je m'en sors si le point de
vue moral j'étais vraiment remonté
croyez moi c'est grâce à cette femme que
j'ai rencontrée région par région les
plateformes des coudes continue de se
développer
du côté du gouvernement il faudra
attendre le début des années 90 pour
voir apparaître les premières campagne
nationale contre les violences
conjugales en 1992 le premier numéro
dédié aux victimes est lancé dans toute
la france où dénonçant la violence
conjugale comme ou
acceptable c'est pour cela que si votre
compagnon ou votre mari vous bonne 10
ont refusé la violence et pour savoir à
qui s'adresser
nous avons créé cette permanence
téléphonique nationale 1 numéros à 10
chiffres remplacer quinze ans plus tard
en 2007 par le 39 19 plus facile à
composer et à mémoriser dans les
situations d'urgence
[Musique]